نقف هنا في موقع تصوير فيلم رعب من الخيال
العلمي اسم الفيلم كرولر ان ذا دارك تجري
احداث الفيلم قبل اكثر من 100 عام خلال
عهد الميجي في اليابان ولكن هذا الفيلم لن
يعرض في السينما بل على موقع يوتيوب
يوتيوب ليس فقط للقطط والكلاب التي تقوم
بحركات غريبه انه موقع للمحتوى المميز ذي
الجوده العاليه ويدير ديفيد ماكدونالد هذا
الاستوديو الخاص بيوتيوب وهو واحد من خمسه
استديوهات توفر لشركاء يوتيوب الاستخدام
المجاني والتدريب نساعد الشركات في ايجاد
الجمهور المناسب وتحسين جوده محتواها
ويمكن لاي شخص اطلاق قناه على يوتيوب احدى
اشهرها قناه تعود لشركه سويديه تدعى بودي
باي ولديها اكثر من 36 مليون مستخدم وفي
يوتيوب يتم تحميل نحو 300 ساعه من
الفيديوهات في الدقيقه الواحده ويرغب
الموقع في ان تكون هذه المقاطع المصوره
ذات جوده عاليه كهذه مثلا فهم يوفرون
الشعر والمكياج وحتى الازياء الغريبه التي
قد يتطلب ارتدائها بعض الوقت وتعقد شركه
توي للانتاج السينمائي والتلفزيوني شراكه
مع يوتيوب لاطلاق المزيد من الاعمال
الدراميه المختصه بالسامو الياباني ويطلق
عليها اسم جي دي جي كي كما تامل الشركه
بجذب مشتركين جدد في واحده من اكبر اسواق
يوتيوب انهم يبنون مواقع التصوير ونحن
لدينا التقنيات العاليه والممثلون
الجيدون ويعمل بوب ويلي وما سهيت توكهات
في ان تحضى الاعمال ذات الجوده العاليه
باعجاب اكثر من مستخدم لموقع يوتيوب سيرفع
ذلك من المنافسه فالالاف ممن يحملون
الفيديو عبر يوتيوب يكسبون ارباحا بمئات
الالاف وذلك عبر عائدات الاعلانات
والرعايه وبعضهم يجنون
الملايين قمنا بتوسيع الافق الذي نعمل
ضمنه ونركز حاليا على المؤثرات البصريه
اكثر من اي وقت مضى يقول جي ار ليبرتو ان
مواقع التصوير بيضه الثمن كهذه لم تكن
ابدا في متناول يد صناع الافلام المستقله
ويؤكد ها تجعل من جوده اعماله اكبر ولعل
ذلك هو الاهم بالنسبه لهؤلاء الفنانين
اكثر من تحميل فيديو سينال ملايين
المشاهده توكيو